If we want an interval width of 1 10th, we need to choose the value that's 1
10th away from 1.5 and 1 10th away from 1.7. That value is 1.6. So, our new
intervals then are going from 1.5 to 1.6, and then from 1.6 to 1.7. Now, the
value of the function at 1.6 is negative. So, that means our zero must lie
between 1.6 and 1.7 since we know that the function is positive at 1.7. So,
what have we done? Well, we started out with a big graph of this function, this
quartic function. And we were able, through testing different values of x and f
of x to zoom in on one of the zeros of that function. We've narrowed down it's
location to a really small interval. An interval of just 1 10th. That's really
tiny, considering we started out looking at the domain going from negative 3 to
3. We can see how powerful the intermediate value theorem really is.